what's going on guys it's brandon
williams and i'm here in atlanta for
street to style brought to you by t-so
and bleacher report today i'm gonna be
joined by my guy clint capela and
together we're gonna find somebody on
the streets of atlanta with dope style
and surprise them with a tiso watch
how are you doing finally
really it's been a minute it's like
we talked last season i think we were
able to sit down we talked about stuff
yeah when i go to uh
to my closet
with the music and stuff it's just like
okay i saw today i'm going to wear it
it helps with my whole life you know you
brought the uh are these the cardigans
you already know
and it is about the accessories right
over there what is that the prx yeah
yeah
yeah they made it back in the 70s so
it does have that like retro vibe a
little bit
where are you at right now with your
style well honestly i try to i try to
keep a variety on it yeah uh sometimes i
like to get it cozy with like a mirror
jeans okay uh some nights i'm gonna go
with the suits got you sometimes i like
to forget for the games i like to go
with the jock bands and maybe uh exactly
what y'all plays like batman and stuff
like that is this something that you
would do like in the tunnel i mean
sometimes like whenever we get in the
locker room like i see my teammates walk
in
we like to be like oh that's a nice
little drip that you gotta do
but i would give you a nod to really
influence your teammate because you came
straight off the gate always dressing
yeah i think that says a lot about your
game too you don't take nights off in a
tunnel and you don't certainly don't
take nights on the court exactly um so
being in atlanta obviously this is a
rich city in terms of like style profile
how do you feel the importance of being
somebody in the public eye in the city
has contributed to how you think about
yourself no i really first like i really
first think that's part of the culture
of the city yeah expressing yourself
right you drift listen we're going to go
and we've got to find
somebody to bless today we're going to
bless them with some compliments but for
you you got the outfit yeah yeah i'm
going to pick out the style okay you got
to pick out the watch got it let's do it
let's go let's do it
what's up man i'm brandon what's up man
what's up
man you know popped in here saw you
super stylish dude what's your name in
chris chris yeah okay what's up man you
from atlanta yeah i'm from here man
that's what's up well you got some dope
style going on i like the pants the
shoes the whole puffer tell me a little
bit about your style man like what
inspires you oh man i just like being
comfortable really i like
you know the whole the tech wear i mean
have you on outerwear okay winter is my
favorite time of year so that's what's
up man so like is there anybody in the
nba that likes inspires your style it's
a toss-up okay obviously it's almost a
tie between jordan clarkson and lebron
really okay two different types of
styles jay clarkson is the guy
a characteristic of their style is their
accessory game right i see you have some
great shades on yourself is that
something that you incorporate into your
style yeah you know kind of gravitated
towards it plus you know i actually wear
glasses too so those are prescriptions
no
they aren't prescriptions
these in case you know just for style i
mean i've worked contacts what's up one
of the cool things that i love about my
own personal style that i take from the
nba is accessories particularly my watch
game you know what i'm saying i'm gonna
make sure like this actually is a t-cell
t-touch yeah it's a little big bigger
face and uh chronograph but also like
solar powered so it's got some cool
attributes technological advancements
thank you for taking the time out to
talk to me about your style
and as a compliment to your style
compliments of tiso we want to give you
a watch
brought to you by my man clint capela of
atlanta hawks british how are you doing
man
what's up boys what's up man man thank
you for joining us so we could go ahead
and get my man right listen let's see
what what uh what t-cell got for you
here f-15 soap
oh that's dope
yeah it's a teso prx80 and it is a
heritage vintage watch style that they
brought back this watch is really the
embodiment of versatility so you're
going to be able to put that on what you
got yeah and if you got to go night on
the team complete that style you know
exactly you're knocking these free style
off man grasp on that dog
[Music]
you